I got a snows you came yeah we gotta
talk about this I understand you had a
little bit of an accident I did what
happened I'm so bored yes sorry okay I'm
just gonna you know it was a wrestling
match with Dave Batista's okay all right
you had a little wrestling match with
someone you fell you hurt stuff you're
on the mend but you're getting better
and you've got a cane I do I had
crutches about three days ago right
canes here's why I bring this up I'm
fascinated canes they're so cool look
how pretty that is
I'd love to tell you smile but I
borrowed it from a friend okay that is
really yeah nothing says Jodie Foster Oh
God
tiny skull I remembered when I was a kid
just just thinking when I was a kid like
oh I'd see people with canes I think
games would be really cool good
affectation isn't it yeah like same top
of the morning to you how are you forgot
a cane I'd be doing all kinds of
business I'd be tapping people with a
you right there I would do that all the
time are you having fun with it yeah I
am it's like a Harry Potter thing
[Laughter]
you